[Music]
[Music]
she
[Music]
[Music]
this is a testing on my mic tell me what
you guys do do you hear anything does it
sound bad what's going on some of you
guys like to tell me about audio issues
after the podcast so we're not doing
that today tell me now or forever hold
your peace
oh yeah it does sound good i just
listened to it all right so this is how
we're going to go man this is how we're
going to go
we're going to have a dave
with the realm you know cog
is
at pax west
salva is still recovering from uh his
surgery so we gonna have a day
with the realm now we i did get some
questions from from you guys you know
got some pretty pretty good questions
you know we'll
we'll tackle that first
so let me see that we'll talk about
first so pretty much what we'll go over
is some of the questions i did say uh
members we will be answering member
questions first
and then
and then what we will do from there is
we will go on to regular questions now
i did look at i i think we'll do this
for about 30 minutes maybe 45 i don't
want to do it too long
but what i did see is
you know i feel like we will be able to
get through all the questions there's
not like an absurd amount so i do think
you know we have a good chance of
getting through all the all the
questions
this is not a sunday attic show i wasn't
like see here's the thing like iops ran
off of a different account and i didn't
feel like looking up the info i was like
nah we just we're just going with this
one yeah i didn't feel like doing all
that
yeah
i wasn't looking up all that that that
that's
that that is
for addict with with a c adequate
fatigue is who i am today and i ain't
doing none of that stuff
uh so
momentarily give us a couple more
minutes uh we we are getting stuff
together you know put in the comment
section what games would you guys like
to play with us now
i did look there is like there's a lot
of options
but these people that have like these
servers
it is weird like they want you to like
sign up for betas or and like we don't
even care to buy servers but it's not
even that it's not even
a quick option like that like if i want
to do something on fortnite like you
gotta sign up to some
some
like actual program like you can't just
go in and do
custom lobbies like that which is weird
to me i don't know which is weird to me
uh so you know we're go we're gonna
answer some of these questions some of
you guys answer some good questions now
uh what i will put like i said i i'm
gonna put this in the chat go ahead go
through there you know i put the actual
link to the description in the chat
that's where the questions will be
answered now keep in mind like i said
members and patreons you know you're
going to get your questions answered
first and then anyone else after that
we'll get to that after that but we'll
see you guys here in a minute
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
me
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
what's going on guys all right so this
is how we're gonna do it we're gonna
come across
these these questions first you know
like i said members get their questions
answered first uh i don't
i want to be very clear on that because
if we don't get to some i don't want to
hear now we playing favorites no the
people who got their stuff for it it's
just how it is like it is what it is
like
kinks he says it all the time man
recolor first look
they are our uh our blood even though
you know the people that show up are our
blood too
but it's it's just the fact that you
know they go above and beyond and
sometimes you got to give their
recognition you know it's like extra
credit and homework see how i've always
had it and that's why like you guys all
you get the content
it's just they get ants ask the
questions first like i like to give
insinuates where everyone still feels
like they gotta consume the content but
the members got to dictate the content
in a way if you get what i'm saying
yep
you know already i'm down with all that
stuff what you saying
all right so
let's let's start with
let's start with a
hustle and motivate
man he he'd been a member for a minute
but he has over under how many years
until jim ryan is fired by sonny i'd say
under three
how many years before jim ryan's fired
by sony yeah by sony
never
never you don't think there ain't
nothing he can get fired
no
he right now he's going to go down the
most successful
um
ceo
for the playstation brand
that they've ever had
like he's phil's
evil doppelganger he's like he's from
zebra doppelganger
he he he's he's
he's the evil reflection in the mirror
like you know how you go to a clown
house and they get a weird distortion of
you
but see the thing is
and the playstation
fan base may not want to hear this
it's for your own good
it's for your own good because the
multiplayer
they need these games
um they need the games of service they
need to start going to pc
they need to do these things and under
the old regime you wouldn't did these
things you had those
same
things man so
i'm sorry but um
that man right there
he's what he's greatness yeah games
ain't greatness no more
oh but he's walking greatness in that
building so that whatever he says goes
bro
when he when he decides to leave he's
gonna leave it's not gonna be like uh
like this guy that they ousted out and
um sean later it's not gonna be like
sean
that's not gonna happen
and he he made strides in ways that
to this day
makes playstation profitable this
playstation 5
is the first console
from launch that was proc uh profitable
and it's the first console
to ever go up in price two years in with
the same hardware matter of fact no they
made it lighter and and took stuff out
and sold fire
now he ain't going no place
[Music]
yeah and remember you know we've been
saying for a while uh that you know he's
gonna end up being
the uh he's gonna make more money than
everyone else combined at the end of his
reign
yep
all right so
i'm gonna put in the chat
because i do think that
you know obviously there's going to be a
playback on this but i do think people
coming in
up in the chat
has a lot to do with what we should play
too i mean we could play among us too
i didn't even think about that it's on
game gameplay everything
hold on let me let me let me get among
us um you got me downloading it's it's
700 megabytes you downloaded instantly
almost no
it's it's it's no problem it's not that
it's that
i'm downstairs on
the series s in the red room i'm not on
one of the x's that's upstairs i got an
x in the bedroom and x in the purple one
so all right so here i put a we'll give
you guys well by the time we finish
these questions whatever has the most
we'll play that with you guys for about
an hour and then we're probably gonna
pop out
uh just depends how much fun we're
having uh you know we do got lives we do
got lives and you know me and king
technically do it over time with the
lords in here with you guys right now so
respect out there
all right all right i just felt addict
and i felt that you needed something and
you're not saying that cog and sovereign
don't stop sovereign definitely can't we
wouldn't let him anyway he wanted to
can't go sit down um and cog is
please everybody if you don't follow cog
on twitter go follow cog on twitter
right now
um and every video that pops up that man
is out there solo dolo doing a hundred
percent of the lord's work and for
reasons you know uh
you know they're going down with the
team
we couldn't go but he made sure that he
did the duty and he's out there so yeah
love and respect
he's out there all the content you're
seeing on youtube i might be doing like
a lot of the editing and stuff but
that's all cog like he's out there doing
all that by himself like that's all
called so definitely pop in when you see
tikal you know especially defining dude
you know send them a comment saying you
appreciate all the packs west going to
we'll be there next year but this year
just didn't fall in line with us
looks like we're going to be playing hey
long be real just uh king already halo
went about 40 but anyway all right so
all right so
question okay so i gotta make sure
lucious augustus would you rather see
your favorite series die slowly or be
put on ice for use for years potentially
forever
all right i got i i
he said would you rather see your phone
no i know
to me i'd rather see it on you like okay
look i want to put some context behind
this i know it's not context that he put
in here
but
is there good years of seeing this this
franchise die slowly that's why i wanted
to no he said slowly so you know damn
good yes they got to be good years
because
look king mean you both know they're not
going to keep something alive is it like
the walking dead where people feel like
it's dying slowly but it's still having
great ratings or is it like dying slowly
that i no longer mess with that
franchise and that's why i feel like
it's dying slowly
great ratings doesn't make it a great
product
you know just because the populace is in
love with the product doesn't mean that
it's a great product so
i'm taking what he says and and and i
could be wrong
but die slowly means he got stabbed up
in the street and he's dragging his
corpse across the block
i don't want that i think i'd rather see
it on ice i think i'd rather see it on
ice yeah put it put it in the bushes and
until somebody can actually and this is
about halo man that's about halo
you know that's that's about halo and i
understand exactly what he's talking
about now
but somebody's gonna give a specific
halo question so i don't want to jump
out the window yet
look all right so uh
all right so the next question is
[Music]
uh donna taku hold
yeah
it is um
one um one upcoming xbox game has to get
cancelled so i don't even like the
beginning of this question donna taku i
don't like this
let me finish reading it
uh is to get canceled so your favorite
upcoming or rumored xbox game gets
released tomorrow in perfect complete
condition which game would use oh so
he's pretty much saying
uh one upcoming xbox game has to get
canceled so your favorite game gets
released tomorrow what would you
sacrifice to get your favorite game
which game do you sacrifice
which game to get my favorite game
pretty much like a game that they're
working on now you would sacrifice
another game they're
they're working on to get your game in
full condition tomorrow what game would
that be that you would sacrifice
for what game that they have that you
want i'll give you an example because i
know
uh so i would sacrifice help blade 2 for
fate in a heartbeat in a heartbeat it
wouldn't even it wouldn't it wouldn't
even be hesitation i would sacrifice
hellblade 2
for
it's got to be dominant games not like
you know
passion project games games that were
you know develop like a handful of
developers making it's got to be a
substance like you can't get rid of like
grounded for the outer worlds too you
know what i'm saying
yeah let let me um
damn that's a hard one but i would
definitely get rid of hellblade 2 with
the quickness for a fable game because i
don't really i'll probably review it for
the channel because i know you guys
probably will want my uh my uh
experience with the game as being
someone that didn't really couldn't play
the first one a whole lot uh but i
put fable so much higher on the totem
pole than than late too it's not even
it's not even a question
i i would say
um
what's what's what's that game a vow
a vowel oh you're gonna get rid of a vow
you can't do that to me king
i i i will get rid of a vow
because okay and then
let me give you my rationale right
you have a ton of rpgs coming
so
you have fable
which we don't know what style they're
going for but we're hoping that it's in
traditional style so you're looking at a
a character
a regular character that is already made
that is central to it like link or you
know to the world so you know nothing
that you're gonna you know change around
um
then you have starfield
right
you know what no
i would sacrifice red for red yeah i
could see that i would if there was
another game it would be red fall i
would i would sacrifice you know i'm
gonna give you a second one i would
sacrifice red fall for a vow
i i would sacrifice red maybe maybe no
foreign six that's what i was
sacrificing for elder scrolls
my sacrifice would be
red fall for um
a senior saga
a senior saga awesome yeah
you're pretty much gonna you you you
gotta
i'm gonna i'm gonna yeah i'm gonna take
you what you threw out and put it right
back
oh it is what it is that was a good
question man i appreciate that i'm
talking
uh we got another member k johnson are
you concerned about the lump
the low we we're still waiting on game
pass for xbox studios
the lowell we still have waiting on
games from xbox studios i think he's
pretty much saying are you concerned
about oh that's
kate johnson's a woman
um
all right so
okay um all right so my daughter's a
baker right and you know she bakes cakes
if if i was to rush her process i would
have a nasty cake
and we've had plenty of those
we've we've had plenty of nasty cakes
and i'm just not the guy
you know to you know tell my daughter
because uh i love the xbox brand like
like it's one of my kids
and
you know when she makes a bad cake
everybody's sitting there with the face
like yeah man you did a good job and i'm
like bro they're saying that
so
um i'm gonna have to keep it real 100
at all times so i'm going to tell her
you know hey take your time
build it and it's gonna come so am i a
little frustrated yeah i'm actually 100
frustrated with the low of especially
this year
uh but again
we already know what's happening in the
beginning of next year and microsoft is
being present at all these shows it's
not like they they bury their heads in
the sand and they're hiding no they're
outside they're telling you what they're
working on and they're working hard
yeah i'm pretty much the same like i do
this year has been pretty dry in terms
of you know the content that i want to
consume
but i do feel like until we start seeing
these games i can't
like
i can't question too much like we got to
actually see the games
yeah because it's not like you know
like you're getting a a game that was
made in uh 1990 released on the
playstation 5 the gran turismo um it's
not like you get in uh cross-gen title
that's really a playstation 4 title that
was just up resin pro
it's not like
you oh let's see it's a remake of a
remake of a remake of a remaster or
something that just came out that is
whatever
it's 70 so
they're not beating you in the head with
old stuff and trying to re-skin it and
and sell it to you that that's the easy
way to do it right they could do that
and have something to show for the year
like the competitors so i'd rather you
come with new experiences these are new
ips that we've been screaming for years
about so it's going to take some time
man yeah
so let's go ahead and get a
all right
we are done with the member chats for
right now until
people post more member stuff okay so i
like this question i'm going to answer
the questions that i like
um
james still
obviously
that's just who i am like i'm the one
reading the questions so that's who's
getting read we got james
excellent should ied take over halo
okay
you gonna take it first
yeah i don't i i think the only studio
that's qualified to do halo right now is
343. i just think that we you know we
we're to a point where maybe a
management needs to be
redone or you know maybe uh some
leadership needs to be
changed over there at 343 i don't
exactly know what's going on over there
there's something clearly going on i
don't know if it's a combination i don't
know if it's the pandemic i don't know
if it's like you know
the perspective of what they wanted the
game changed multiple times throughout
the uh throughout the development i
don't know if it's the engine or maybe
it's a combination of all these things
but i do feel like there's clearly
something going on at 343 that needs to
be addressed but in terms of what studio
needs to work on halo i don't think
there's another studio that is out there
that is more qualified than 343. i just
think that
the the
maybe the person that's leading the ship
needs to change or at least
i just feel like
when it comes to this particular studio
we see more bad than good and i think
that's the issue
i think the ambition is the issue
i think they're so damn ambitious
that um
they over they they
over promise another little delivery
uh
the ambition is their problem
they want to be so grandiose
because i guess walking through the
microsoft halls halo is this mythical
creature
and if they're not going to legendary
status if they're not going super saiyan
budokai five you know it's it's it's
just
not necessary right it's just why should
we even try like we're going to do co-op
and we're going to do forge we're going
to do multiplayer free to play and we're
going to launch a single player campaign
that's free open world we're going to do
it all on the same day man shut up
uh
the problem is the ambition
and and
looking at
other free-to-play models that are
solely based around the free-to-play
model itself that gear all the energy
towards that right you don't have apex
legends have uh um bless you uh you
don't have apex legends have a
single-player uh open-world story-driven
game
right oh that you get that multi-player
to it go up to it but you know they
don't have that right
uh
so
you gotta look at what they're trying to
do and i think they overreach the grass
or over promise the grass
and the expectations of once you say it
is already out there
that's a
big problem that ambition
and i think
if you get somebody who's level headed
there in charge to reign in those
ambitions and to give something that's
coherent
i think that works more
yeah and uh i'm still uh i'm seeing uh
hargie cheney he he put in chat he said
leadership did
already change chris out joe in lots of
personal changes at 343 unfortunately
that doesn't make a difference in the
matter of days it took phil uh to turn
around xbox i i agree to disagree now i
do think there hasn't been enough time
for us to really see
you know cr uh you know chris's i mean
joe's actual joe staton's actual vision
he wants halo infinite to be
but i do think that the little things
like you know coming out there and
pretty much
they've done some very bad pr moves here
lately
like stuff like that you could easily
stop happening
and you know just little things like the
lack of that you know that map you know
it was it the worst map that we've ever
seen no but i do think that coming from
the perspective of someone that you know
may have played a lot of halo and i've
dropped table infinite for a little bit
you know i don't play it as much as i
used to
and seeing a map like that that always
entice me to go back and play i'm gonna
be real with you guys like is it cool
sure uh but i do feel like you know i
agree with you hargie that we need to
have a little bit more time before we
start seeing joe's actual vision how he
wants halo infinite to be but the thing
is is
the consumers don't owe them that time
if they don't want to play the game they
don't have to play that game i'm not
saying that you're saying they have to
play the game but it's just like
regardless what happens
you need to give some form of content
that's why i said they should have
outsourced and had people you know would
have been nice uh king if they opened up
this this season with like five or six
old classic maps you know what i'm
saying and it's like
there's not a world to me
where if they if they really wanted to i
feel like they could make those classic
maps they're already made they just got
to remake them in the engine that the
system belongs into
and it's just like i don't know nothing
about the development but to me that
feels like they could do relatively
maybe not soon maybe not even a long
time but we would have seen them by now
if they would have started that in the
beginning of the process now i think
that's the issue is like we don't see
the we don't see the progression to
going on the other side of the mountain
we keep slipping down this icy mountain
and we don't see it melting any like you
know you know you know
what's the problem
forge
i think for just
i think ford just holding up their maps
because they're like yeah
you have the fans make it i've seen the
forged stuff is incredible
you know i seen somebody make the whole
toy story uh room the kids room
you know um so
i think i think forge is the problem
when it comes to them to the maps that
are being given out but also the biggest
problem right about now
is the fact that you're not saying when
forge is coming
it was forged and i'm pretty sure
everybody is shut up
yeah i agree so we got about 12 more
minutes of questions and then we're
going to move on to the game
um
ducky said can i help you all get a
king's fall running no not not this
stream ducky not this stream
uh let's let's see
what do you think
he was good i gotta get on with you yeah
i'm not gonna try to
pronounce your name i'm gonna butcher it
so we're gonna move past that uh but
someone in the community in the realm
says what do you think about achievement
system i would like the xbox to do like
sony especially separate the base game
from dlc so i think what he's talking
about is like when you go and you look
at a lot of these xbox games
uh you will uh
sony separates the dlc they're not
actually part of the uh you know the
the platinum you can get a platinum
multiple things i don't know if if you
get a platinum in the dlc but they
separate them so it doesn't like
de-platinum you when it comes to the
base game if i if i know i don't might
not know the system correctly but he
just pretty much wants to know is there
any changes you want to make when it
comes to the achievement system on xbox
i stopped focusing on the achievement
system when uh the level of games that i
have to play is outpacing my time
uh before when that first happened me
and mr ha
went at gaming score
ridiculously
i'm talking about
every day we will we will flip we will
get games just to get the achievements
out to get that that uh 1k
achievement and um that was about it i
don't care if it was arnold palmer's
golf i don't care what it was um
my little pony i remember i had uh what
was it was it was barbie something i
rented barbies from redbox just to get
the achievement it was the easiest
achievement in the world um
i don't care about the platinums
i don't care about the
the gaming score
um
none of that stuff really entices me i i
don't care and i care
i don't care to go out and try to do it
i care when it pops up
and i see it i go oh cool
that's it so
if they separated for for people that
care
yeah you should have your your 1k score
there and then they should have a
separate bracket for dlc i believe
that's right that's the best way to do
it you know for people that care about
that stuff so my world is not
everybody's world and i have to live
with everybody in this world so yeah
separated yeah i do feel like the the
the trophy system is superior to the
achievement system because of the
platinum feature on sony
i think that's the biggest thing i
thought
that
the
rare achievement was going to be
platinums back in the day but that ended
up just being achievements that you've
gotten that a lot of people haven't
gotten like your very small percentage
of that and i think that yeah those
diamond achievements yeah i think that
uh that should have you know diamond
achievement that's what it should have
been called like when you complete a
game you get a diamond achievement i get
it but i do feel like you know they
should answer that platinum trophy and i
i think it's safe to say since it's been
so long they haven't answered it they're
probably not going to at this point
which you know it's hard to tell
sometimes
there's a lot of things on the list
but there's not a lot of time people do
stuff so you have to you have to wait
for it you know i know for a fact that
dvr is
one of the things on microsoft's list to
address but when you got 20 other things
that's way more important to get to at
this exact moment you only have a
certain amount of resources and staff to
do things sometimes stuff has to be
pushed back
so i definitely understand that so uh
i did it does look like uh halo one uh
so i think we'll we'll we'll go into the
halo
halo infinite
okay it's not downloading it but i can
play through the crowd so there's no
problem oh is it do you not have it
finished downloaded yet
no
we'll play something else though it's
cool
uh what what i got um
um
fall guys are among us because they both
have like things that goes on the the
screen where you can like are
those games our people can actually play
and they can just put in a name and play
it with this
so let me let me get four guys and make
sure i got four i think fall guys would
be the easiest because we like we don't
have to i mean we can get a bunch of
people in here and play among us but you
know how it is so certain people will
will try to come in here and say some
off-the-wall stuff so i try to
keep voice to a minimum you know we
probably only get people in here that
like we know and trust or
or people that's been in the chat for a
certain amount of time you know well i
mean if somebody comes in and they curse
they go i don't know
it's not even the cursing thing some
people will come in here and place them
off the wall and stuff so
oh you're doing music and stuff yeah
yeah it's stuff like that too get his
band how long before king downloads halo
i don't know probably kale is a very big
game
oh i could do cloud no i could do cloud
that's nothing you have to worry about
sorry about that do you want to play
fall guys or halo
i'm putting four guys in right now
i got uh i got among us there and um
yeah this down here i'll just be playing
fortnite
yeah we'll see what i'm uh
well i guess i'll load up fall guys uh
now i don't know if you guys have ever
hey hell don't worry
yeah i actually need to help someone
finish that
um
yeah i actually been hoping people
finished that game
uh so how this goes is uh
keep in mind fall guys is cross playing
the good thing about fall guys we we can
rotate people you can have up to like 60
people and fall guys too
uh so it's really going to help keep
people you know constantly playing
i don't know how many what's the most
you can have on
on
fortnight is it 60
um
yeah
so they said that the halo multiplayer
is only 32 gigs king
okay
how long is it downloaded like before
it's done
i told you i could play
in the cloud
okay uh if you're if you if you have no
problem playing the cloud we'll play
halo
i got no problem
this is the series s that i'm on right
now come here come on
and bro know don't don't tease me bro
lucius not everyone has that i mean i
think king has fiber but
it's just like look like oh yeah i do
how how
much of the gigs in
and what was it uh under a minute
all right okay okay don't come for me
lucious the the then what we'll do is
claw that close out of all your stuff
and we'll answer like one or two more
questions and give it a little bit more
time to download
look go ahead i can play in the cloud
i'm i'm fine okay
forever wait bruh
like it's all good on this side right
now if it was the playstation i'm gonna
have to be like well guys you know
i didn't know what was gonna play so i
didn't wanna you know
no no bruh
that's what it is all right i got all
these gigs and stuff from down here open
hopefully
all right so let's go ahead and get this
took care now i haven't played halo in a
minute
uh but
you know i think we play some big team
battle
because we do got over 200 people in
here and our and we are
we do got a lot of uh xbox
people in here so i'm assuming we're
gonna be able to get some people
yeah somebody was hitting me
and saying we need to play more sea of
thieves in the community joint and more
halo
my guy
don't be expecting me to do that on my
free time because on my free time i'm in
that fortnight baby
all right so let's get people in here
first
right
look at hariat cd pop to him almost
instantly
let me get him in here
now if you guys want a party invite
just hit me up and i'll send you one
like i said you want some cr so
some stuff like you you get out of there
and i'll put you i'm gonna have a a
microsoft word
that i'm gonna keep all all the other
people on there that that
that aren't being nice
who's who's prince cloud i don't know
but let me let me get him in here he
said
he said invite me
actually this would be a good time let
me um let me hit up kid too smoothly
i added you as a friend prince so
you don't have to you know like
message me
silently
let me go down here
to the microsoft store find halo and
just put cloud play the gamer tag is
this
what's up you want to play some halo
with the with the realm and me and king
all right man i'm just giving you the
invite i'll talk to you later
all right
so that that's the uh
it's lord addict with that little weird
hashtag thing 4278 that's what it is but
if you guys send me a message i can get
you in here too
invite yes you can come in here
tactical
i'm trying to put it to play cloud
how do i just
because this is installing right now and
i want to play with cloud
it tells you play with cloud gaming
oh my god i can't keep up with all the
people we can only have a certain amount
of people in here yeah we're going to
rotate
we we'll get through everyone man we'll
get through everyone
it's k johnson uh she wants in here
she done gave how many giga j sure come
on [ __ ] james she done brought so many
stuff
may i have a game
okay he doesn't want to participate
what's up fellas
what's going on
chillin chill
let me grab addict's invite
okay thank you bro
why does i need to search this game
when i'm already in the cloud mode
connecting to the lobby
sinking with the guardians
so so king i think we should uh do my
team versus yell team
your team versus my team yeah are you
talking about
we're on the same team together bro
don't play that stupidness with me i'ma
be on eagle you could be on cobra you
know we're gonna we're gonna draft our
own oh
you acting up here
this dude is acting really strange
really strange indeed
all right let's see what's happening
here all right we can get one more
person for this game and then we'll have
to rotate people next game
yo
i just keep saying i need to install
this game
but i'm in
the cloud
this is stupid
all right here goes my friends
oh do i need to be online let me know
let me put myself online
now i'll be appearing offline you know
yeah
i forgot my guardian
my spartan
has a
missile a mistletoe head
all right where are you at
i don't even see you on
all right big team battle i gotta
remember how to do all this
uh i don't like behemoths yeah i i can't
join this match i've been trying to join
this match everybody's in his match
uh not yet hold up
yeah nobody can join your joint
every time i grab it well for me it says
you need to install this game or app for
this make sure you sign in xbox i am and
it's downloaded in the background and i
got my screen right here
now let me see where you at
on my friends
because
the wildest thing is you're not even
popping up as a friend of mine
which is stupid i'm online i checked
actually
let me put do not disagree oh there you
go
addict
right here okay got it
invite to fighting
invite to gain a party
you know what i might invite everybody
that's inside this party to my game
all right so everybody go to observer
but me and king we're we're going to
drive people we're going to drive people
hold on and the best thing about it i
don't know how how good anyone is
because i never played with anyone
because i played with fargy but that's
about all
changing in halo 5
huh
king
yeah king invited me to halo 5 oh you're
in halo 5 king you're not you're not
playing halo
[Laughter]
king downloaded
oh my god
oh what in the world
oh my god king in halo 5 man
king where are you at are you talking
hey
yo
here i'm promoting you the leader uh uh
set us up for a big team battle there's
a lot more people joining and i can't
remember how to do any of that we could
do a custom game
well it might
all right
this is
king kicking left in shame king will be
back
[Laughter]
he said he left the [ __ ]
oh
did you promote me i don't i still see
you as the leader
yeah i did promote you i don't know i
didn't work oh there we go now i am yep
oh my god we got a lot of people in here
playing man
this is
try to pick a big map man
oh no it says
i don't know what's going on
oh my god see they came
you know what i ain't gonna even say
none i ain't gonna even say no i'm gonna
keep my mouth shut
um send me another message uh lucius i
can send you one just send me another
message
did it do it again
yeah it still says just tell me how to
do it just tell me how to do it
how to do custom games yeah no
i'm in custom games i just don't know
how to get to be big team battle i can't
remember
oh it's in mode so when you go into
custom you have to uh mode select and
then the
uh first thing is the uh the type and
then you can select big team is it 343
industries
yes
oh you first okay never mind number one
you have to press uh left trigger to
move it
big team battle capture the flag i like
that let's play that
but let's change the map because uh we
we we want good maps
all right so what we're going to do uh
um king
clearly
having issues uh i can hear him lighten
up but he's not talking
can anyone else hear king maybe he
blocked me i don't know maybe he blocked
me
nope i can't hear him
all right so we're just gonna go ahead
and uh
start the game
play one game while we wait for king
i don't know what's going on there
but what we'll do is we'll set we'll set
the uh the mode
scores to win is two so you only got to
score twice
and what's the time
that's good
all right hold up someone said they sent
a message to play
sorry guys it's it's kind of
overwhelming right now i got so many
people messaging me at once
it's the first time we've ever done
anything like this you guys have to give
me a little break
all right we're gonna have to have some
people from green go to cobra man
we got to have some green go to cobra
how many we missed one two three six one
two three four never we're good now
we're good now
it did it did well
see where king is where's king i mean
all right we can hear you good
yeah i texted you uh uh my phone my
battery out and i was like what the hell
is going on
and um said now the invite
yes please sir
all right we need one more person let me
get one more person up here
i think they i you know i don't know
what's up with this
uh
yeah me boy
yeah we hear you we hear you what's up
yama
you guys hear me okay yeah yeah are you
fine man we hear you fine all right
thanks glad to be here
glad to have you
now if only my uh foolish self
can actually uh get into his damn game
because
i don't like everybody else
you know using halo 5 don't you
huh you was playing halo 5 earlier
i'm in halo infinite well the people
that was in the uh the chat said you
were sending them an invite to halo 5.
raleigh was probably close
yeah yeah
you about that right
yeah you know what yeah yeah you're
right you're right you're right
all right so we
what's going on i tried to accept an
invite but it it dropped me off that
custom game by myself i don't know what
happened
look at me we can't even say this is
what i'll be talking about man
hey hey man you got to blame microsoft
yeah
oh my god
this is why you supposed to oh but you
did call me last night oh yeah i did i
told you
no and i told you to text me
i sent you a text
i said i can't talk right now please
text me
and you said nothing sir
okay king
put the blame on that it's okay
no but i mean you know you know i'm
right don't lie don't lie got five
dollars you draft from free r kelly
kang i'm gonna why are you playing this
dead game microsoft killed a flagship
title sony can't be stopped that sony
bungee deal looking good
hey hey free hawk kelly how's that last
of us
i freaked out kelly instead instead of
talking that smack in the chat won't you
come in here and pick up this pistol
well he know he can't because he don't
have the common room
[Laughter]
lights out go to peck
[Laughter]
i'm doing a restart on the game to see
if that helps i don't know
i'm trying to just play it in the cloud
are you guys in the game yet
no i'm just saying
yo why don't we play uh four guys real
quick while while this is doing oh come
on man
wait wait wait a second you should like
[ __ ] you should have been you should
have at least had this downloaded
already or be in the cloud let's go okay
okay
first of all i'm trying to get in the
cloud but
but my my behind was in halo 5. okay
this is what we're going to do this is
what we're going to do hold up hold up
this is what we're going to do i have no
idea
i'm i'm crazy like that it's sunday man
my business so someone from someone from
our team can somebody please send
another invite to me okay uh once we get
this individual in here we'll play a
game while it finishes down on your end
thank you
i loved it
let me close everything else out
there we go
so we got seven on six is people okay
with that
yep
oh man that was quick
no no we need someone else in my team
[Laughter]
at least he's real bad he's like no i
got six i'm gonna need i'm gonna need
someone else
[Music]
all right is everybody happy
i don't care i'm pushing play
i'm good
i'm good we're even now
all right let's go
some reason deep down in my soul i feel
like this team's unbalanced i don't know
why
but deep down in my soul i feel like
this team is extremely unbalanced and
this ain't gonna work well for
for someone i don't know if it's my team
or the other team but someone about to
get destroyed
capture enemy flags to score
to get used to because i'm i'm still
getting used to using a bumper jumper
too so you have to get used to that
i apologize for the team i'm on right
now
attic is doing bumper jump
man i got to get used to jumping
yeah you could join the next game man
you could join the next game we got you
guys we got you
that's why i kept the
game selection that's why i kept the uh
the questions to a minimum because you
know we want to be playing these sticks
instead of answering questions all day
oh look at you how thoughtful you are
no i'm not thoughtful i just don't want
to answer questions
i don't ask some questions all day
either that's why i'm downstairs in my
revenue and close the door and my wife
[Laughter]
they on the left
whoever's on addict's team i don't know
who's on whose team
yet man so i don't know we'll see
you don't got a kill yet ah man this is
what i'm talking about see what i'm
talking about these guys
okay
oh my god they got a flag
too
oh my
[Music]
pennywise is extremely horrifying
get him oh get get that
so check this out right and i'm gonna
give you a helpful hand
for anybody
oh my god they're everywhere they're
everywhere
of a home invasion nice
fire clowns
uh afro you know the colorful afro clown
afro and a clown's mask
and if anybody breaks into your house
throw on the clown mask
and the afro and run down
with the afros
and say i've been waiting for this my
whole life
yo i'm gonna clip that
i'm gonna clip that
[ __ ] don't let me down [ __ ] don't
let me down hey i'm returning every time
jacob was just gonna stand there and
watch me get murked
nice
it's hilarious
[Music]
on the back and saying good luck son
good luck
ain't no pat on the back
we don't do that
hit you with the bang
wow
you only get the pad if you win
oh there's two people there what was
jacob where was jacob
i remember uh
i need some help ah they got me the
enemy carrier has revealed themselves
all right
oh boy
[ __ ] could have did better there how
much you say that
okay get out of here with that prince
cloud
i'm texting i'm texting prince cloud
right now
get out of that prince cloud
i'm distracting him
you're distracting there go
oh that's what they're gonna kill me
this someone keeps killing me distract
him
don't do prince do someone else
yeah get live supremacy i guess i guess
you were distracting him too
is the game
i guess you're distracting prince cloud
again
no man
oh that was all you hey who has the flag
does anybody have a flag no i ain't
trying to get the flag no more
i'm trying to kill the people king is
distracting
i think the flag disappeared
yeah the game's glitched
look at that we can't play
man
they broke the game
i told y'all we should have played the
manga
look at that man i just want to point
this out here man we can't even play
that's the problem that's sad
then it should have ended
off the setting okay well then the
game's never gonna end
right
right
i still took a glitch because i said
it's the two flags like each of us get a
two one of us get two flags that ends
well i don't know man
they're coming in on me yeah i'ma get me
that's what she said
this is the first time that's ever
happened
look man
see you you guys don't and then this is
all this is all that revenge for me
constantly attacking the chat isn't it
are they putting that word
oh what they got a pineapple
200
i think some of these skins is out of at
uh prices is out of whack is it done is
your game done
i'm in there i'm okay oh you gotta do
something right all right well
okay so we got seven minutes left you
guys just want to quit uh it's neither
no no
no
but that we can't play the objective
we're just sitting here mindlessly
killing people
i think you like that right
it's
my multiplayer isn't down yet
say king you're holding us up
i'm sorry it's all at expo
it is what it is man i'll take the
blanket i'll be in the background and
i'll do background commentary and i can
watch the stream
okay can you come in at his observer we
picked up the skewer
let me get this halo 5 out of here
he downloaded halo 5 that's what
happened
no no no no no no no i can take a
screenshot no i didn't shut up
this guy over here man i don't know who
this guy attic is but he's not a good
guy
it's fine
all right let me quit this
man you are so lucky i don't know this
new control scheme enough to grab you
because uh he he got bumped
prince cloud you thought you had me but
you did
just wreck man someone get the banshee
black guy like five six other teammates
why is that banshee still alive
if king was here that banshee would be
down i'm just saying i'm just saying
don't don't give that level of skills to
me
don't do that don't do that
you may not like
man i'm watching
i'm watching you right now
they go at it
oh oh adam put that work in
oh attic oh come on prince cloud my
they coming after me man we might as
well be playing infection because that's
all they are they want kill the [ __ ]
i've been saying kill the banshee for 30
minutes
i want you guys on that banshee like
white on rice all right i want everyone
on that band
who's in the basket
kill it
that's k johnson in the banshee
oh okay
you see how every week i got to defend
that you're a woman right
there
there's someone coming in
where did that dude go
they keep saying hey hey eddie kate
johnson that's right like
no
you know my son um name is keyshawn
johns keyshawn johnson is my favorite
football player so
my son name is david keyshawn johnson
oh they're coming in from the left
they're everywhere
yo don't don't forget we about to die
though ain't nothing i could do i'm
about to die i met him one time
while i was working and i couldn't
fanboy i was mad as hell
man listen he he talked too much trash
about my bears i don't know how i feel
about it oh i hate you god bless
let's go bears grace
listen i'm a jet fan
yeah exactly
listen i'm a jet man
oh i ran out of ammo
god slices
that's pretty rough listen i'm a yankees
fan but right now i just see them take
their season and pushing it in the
toilet bowl
oh the banshee again damn it guys i
blame everybody i blame jiggy more man
oh my god
how we just gonna let them take that
every time you might as well just sit
there and like
you know what i had to fight off three
people
well then that's two people you should
have killed quicker so you didn't have
to
it's downloading that 200 megabits a
second now was it three best though
yeah get it get it
get the banshee
get the banshee
yo you know that's right
we got him
if you let them get that banshee again
you you you're going to the b team next
yeah
[Music]
phantom cracking we got you man we got
you uh just let this game finish we got
what
47 seconds left and we'll start rotating
people off
yeah you'll still be rude prince cloud
got him got him
yo
i'm over here prince ah
when you got added
where you at on the map
i'm still getting used to jumping with
left bumper it's weird it's taking a
little to get used to stop making
excuses you just take the loss
hey i i i've been holding up my own on
these one-on-ones
i was watching your stream didn't look
like that to me
look here when you can play the game you
can talk to smack this is true this is
true this is true all right i'm just
sitting here watching from the
background
nobody always
are we supposed to play pub g
oh man man someone your knee he keeps
killing me i'm trying to go for that
if i get killed by shinny again i'm done
i'm out
he said why can't you kill him
shut up yo [ __ ]
i'm saying
vocal
you like your new treats yes daddy
they're delicious
again
you know the whole mission
bro
we got a mold called the banshee
i'm calling room on monday you're going
to the groomer
oh there's two of them there's two of
it's too them
two one two spartans one addicts
oh
he says two spartans one addict that
sounds like a movie
no that's not that kind of movie
baby
yeah i think it's just gonna keep going
over time just one more minute right oh
yeah
because i heard it was supposed to end
47 seconds ago and i'm not saying
nothing because
listen
listen check it out i'm at 69 so i'm
just sitting here
and then i watched the stream and i'm at
200 sir please don't come from the
unless i sent you thank you oh man
he gonna keep coming for me first of all
i told you i was playing in the cloud
all right don't come for me playing the
wrong game in the cloud that's what she
was doing
listen i was in the wrong cloud
that's what happens when you don't play
the games at least i can tell you i
don't thought i wasn't playing
whatever
that's right lock up closer lights out
go to bed
i'll drop out for a run somebody else
can play and i'll come back later
who said that
sorry
okay
after he terrorized
oh my god
he's still laughing
all right everybody right now i know we
got some more people uh in here so i'm
gonna this is this is my gamer tag send
me a message on uh xbox
and i will get you in the the most
that's lucious augustus
yeah that's me
gotta add you right now buddy
yo you know you know who she is hold up
lucious i got one question for you it's
gonna determine if you played with this
do you like banshees okay
no
okay we're good we're good we're good
i'm a i'm
anyway
um
i
talk to y'all guys every sunday how come
half of y'all are not on my friend's
list and every sunday i say hey man
follow me on xbox how about that i play
guys for people it's like yeah whatever
king
[Laughter]
yeah they don't believe me no no no
because i'm offline most of the time but
i'm nato
am i in the game
i don't know are you in the game
i don't think i know like yo you got to
see his watch macaulay you got to see
his little avatar
he's like a bart simpson home of chicken
something
all right phantom
yeah he's a he's a bart simpson homer
chicken with glasses
what i mean he's not wrong
you will pee on yourself he's a mart
simpson homer chicken with glasses
yeah he's not wrong
hey can we do a land grab on here
i have no idea what that is
like instead of ctf
phantom shark
or we can play just straight up slayer
oh someone wants to show off we could
just play straight up slayers oh yeah
for real
i don't know
your mouth we should do fourteen instead
of seven oh okay cool
while i'm bored right now i'm adding
everybody that didn't add me so no no
better question king what's your what's
your download better question what's
your download at oh wait i see the boss
oh i'm at 80
it's funny right he's a bart simpson all
right so he's a bart simpson
homer he's the bart homer simpson
chicken
it's hilarious
that's what i said all right all right
chad they can't hear me man i muted the
mic what do you guys think we should
play put in the chat which you guys
think we should play more i'll join all
right just step up what do you guys
think what do you guys want us to play
man you want it to
chaos stuff going on tell me in the chat
do you be
what the realm thinks that we should
play if anybody wants to add me feel
free
that's right everybody should be friends
we play games let's be friends
friend me
switch you gotta give your social
security number that's not gonna happen
until you get in there right so this
this kick the this is the chip
this is a realm mode so we i i asked
around what we're going to play and they
want chaos
really nice
yeah let's let's choose uh like
another btb mode and like can we
increase the amount of people because
right now it's only 7v7 can we do the
full 28 lobby
uh yeah if we get enough people that's a
good idea see we need king in here
before we do anything in him his slow
connections connection i mean
it was not jackie the banshee not jack
was killing me
[Laughter]
i got a playstation 5 upstairs i
switched sides very easy
you know what king i'm not even going to
call you six nine you're 70.
you better not be calling me
i just moved it upstairs i had to blow
it off too paul
yeah
yeah
all right who's talking about the lobby
size who's talking lucious
lucius okay i'll give you
i'll try to give you
he added extra to your name
whatever all right
i'm gonna look for the book oh
with little drinks
[Laughter]
hey luscious
hey man stop playing with me
we're almost finished
i like this man we're gonna have to do
this more often like this i said that
before i like playing with people
[Laughter]
that's on saturdays don't you judge me
so how many people we got in here right
now
i don't know that's why i gave you the
the crown you could come up with all
that headache
yo why did that kick says he's almost
done so i want to wait like three or
four minutes for him
i don't know that mcdonald's on wi-fi he
might be done in 10. so
he's here the mcdonald's wi-fi
this guy right here has jokes we got 17
in here yeah we got 17 in here so you
can just keep adding a few more at it
okay
we only got room for a couple more
people guys so uh so hit me up one spot
here is here is my gamer tag it is lord
attic4278 don't don't even talk about
the numbers the numbers don't exist here
but right now they're relevant so add
lord addicts with a space
hashtag 4278 and then send me a message
and i will get you in
but we only got room for how many
so three four three got one of the best
ones going and then we have 17.
so we have 17.
[Music]
oh
my playstation this is great
all right so how many people we got here
19 i think all right we need one more
person one more person
and i got 17 out of 28. seven seconds
today
mess
wait a second see you on the street
a few people are leaving ducky you
didn't have me as a friend already
ducking
the back of the head
let me see you on the streets king
he's he's in my he's in my clan i'ma
punch in the back of the head when i see
you ducky all right we got 20. that's
good
hey pixel big g's avatar look like me
when i'm doing combat talk
so we have 17 or 20 right now mine's not
updating
uh
i counted 20.
all right so yep
king hearty cheney wants to know if
we'll be doing live streams with the
upcoming disney and marvel and ubisoft
shows
um yeah we planned on it me and addy got
to talk about it we're working on
something in the background that's going
to happen
has everything to do with jk says do you
think that tom and hart will make it to
xbox this year and if so do you think it
will be xbox's best song this year
uh
i hope it does
and it would be because that's the only
exclusive
man
it's it's easy to be the best are you
the only one there right
uh high on life
high
i think that game is going to be
controversial
i have little kids out here i'm scabby
man yeah i love it though i love it i
love it he's like let me add him let me
add him i want to see his blood
i just i just love how the talk to the
weapons
well
conquer could have been done it's just
the pinnacle of greatness you know when
it comes to a platformer so they just
got to get a remaster or remake of it
if higher life can exist because you
know all the vulgarity all that stuff
conquered yeah okay so i don't know a
lot of people know
just in case people come to vietnamese
actually it can just in case people come
in you're like i believe again
and that wasn't called assault
you know playing with kids oh yeah
it was rough we was rough kids
like a fight club
yeah basically
fight club
all right
you know how you go to your friends and
say all right
all right
and king i'm gonna be looking for you on
the battlefield
i don't know why
uh
i can't see the teams i don't know who's
on my team my my gun is live bro
you have a custom yeah i can't see
slaves
we playing a couple games
i want to shoot king david
okay and let's see
[Applause]
[Laughter]
shoot first ask questions last i don't
care
i'll let god sort you
uh yeah
yes sir
yes sir
supremacy
oh oh oh he got the flame off man
they got the flame off
but he got robot legs i'm gonna go to
work
right there there he is get him
yeah
and everybody dies
game of thrones
i should have never messed with that guy
he's a terrible dude
we're spartans we don't give ground we
take it
i already got i took you out
oh my god
it took a lot well there's a snake
yeah we we got some sniper over there
from hell man he's born and raised
somebody where is he
yeah that's what happened this is what
happens when you don't play in a while
thank you no problem
i'm power washing with your blood how
about that oh my god
oh my god
[Laughter]
[Music]
where are you
because if it's not for jack y'all ain't
got jack [ __ ] on me y'all god bless
sorry
let's go
lay down all right hello this is not
right this is all right we're losing i
don't know why
because i'm playing yes god bless
get out of there behind you jiggle j
there's like eight people coming
come on cloud everybody's upstairs
sniper on the left is up there bro
he got assisted by [ __ ]
[Laughter]
he said [ __ ] loaded the bullets
snipers up here
don't want that gun
that's me that did that to you how about
that
[Music]
get away from that oh there's someone
behind me
let me let me get the gun let me get in
the gun
we just switched okay okay i'm coming
i'm coming
[Music]
not jack again
i'm gonna tell you he the only person
killing
oh
oh nice driving whoever's in the seat
you my wink never mind you're not my
wingman anymore that should be better
than this
i said goodbye
unless it's working
i'm relying on you for everything man
you see a spartan sword into
oh there's a ghost next to us why didn't
you tell me about the ghost jiggly
great behind you great behind you he's
got a gravity hammer yeah not your
jacket yeah what is what is what it was
what's up with you bro it's just you bro
it's like nobody else on your team man
for real i got to get him out of here
he said sorry i killed him crying
right here
to the right
to the right
to the right
[Music]
the whole squad is dead
i told you tonight we bathing your blood
let's go oh god
all right
i don't got time
it's good i got mad assist
i never lost to you
oh [ __ ]
now i'm getting my ass attacked
on my back
i tried to jump in that short
come on shoot em
destroy him
go
keep going keep driving up there at the
top
and they got too big
oh over
it's over goodbye
we need seven points
we got this guys don't let him
discourage you all right
on my dead body
oh
hold on hold on don't worry about that
don't worry
oh
no not jack again not jack again i'm
gonna tell you right now he the mvp of
your lead
and he got a hammer watch out
no no
i'm just wondering why he got all these
puppets
it's it's just random drop pause
nah
ah
lucious right there next to you watch
out
[ __ ] ghosts
there's a guy behind us
too far away from action
oh man like supremacy outside of me
hundred percent i love how kings
[ __ ] smack this entire
[Music]
listen i don't care as long as you worry
about
calm down hold up calm down
where can i look at okay x
team lineup give it to
three kills
four steps give it a seven assists give
it to
who's on the the top of your team
let him pick the next thing
okay how do i do that you just click his
name and say promote hopefully it will
work i don't know hopefully it'll work
all right yo wait a second why it looked
like we were down people oh no we're not
um
[Laughter]
nah i'm looking at no no no jack
that dude
i can't promote yeah
he was up there it was like a bri all
right it's fine like american sniper
phantom's crack
look at madrid on your team you went off
soda
that's right that's right don't you what
don't look at madrid at all my your
business all right
let's look at your squad i'm over here
i'm sorting out who's who and what's
what relax
all right hold up i'm gonna leave and
start a new lobby
i think that lobby is you i'm trying to
give you back control
it's fine don't start that and he's and
he's standing there with a hammer
all right so yeah so
we got jared mack with the two dollar
super chat all hell the iop salute the
lords all right what are we going to do
we're going to do a crazy one free for
all fiesta that's what we do oh small
matter
on a small man boy yeah yeah yeah
i got to go to the bathroom
yeah do what you do
see i think i got to do it
under the table not to support each
other no no just me
i scratched your back you scratched back
all right we still need people to join
that means you got to be behind the guy
i don't think we can do
i'm already in battle i don't think we
can do big theme battle fiesta all right
then we won't get it it's fine maybe
you know three four three yeah
stop trying to make your own rules at it
look man
and actually man
remember
you asked for this you put me on the
other squat i told you wherever i go
you want to talk that smack okay okay
okay i got you i got that's a true story
right there wait till people join in
here wait till people join in here then
we're gonna see this smile somebody
you guys got to send me a message man
you heard it right
he on his cell phone
that's madrid whipping behind on the
cell phone
all right lord roughness i got you
yeah
he said i won't end i want in
lord roughness
lord roughness himself
yo i'ma start making i want you to all
look out for this um i'm coming out next
year next summertime y'all should have
them
they're gonna be in everybody's um
who's snapping buttons like that
made me think we was playing i'm like
what's up
oh i'm coming out with personal uh
personal lives like these they're gonna
look like book bags so they're gonna be
on your back
nice little freon you're good
you like it nice drop
wait a second who's shooting
somebody
playing someone
oh
no he's getting he's getting sweaty
he said that he had his elite controller
he broke it down and put it back
together
all right he said okay oh i'll see you
all right all right all right this is
what we're going to do is what we're
going to do
everyone go to observer everyone but me
and king go to observe
observer yes i don't know
just push right bumper into your
observer at the bottom
yeah everybody yes everybody but me and
king
are you drafting yes we drink we're here
for the draft oh we're dropping hold on
wait let's go
wherever all right bumper press rb
oh yeah i got you guys i can't see the
liner first i've never done that
even see that work where are you king
are you in here
oh yo i don't i'm right there
he went to the bathroom
i don't i don't see king in here
i still don't see him i don't i don't
see attic though i i don't see attic
i i see that all right all right
we're redoing another one and i'll never
play
i'm sorry guys after today there will
not be another time we play this okay
i'm sorry look at the issues
look at the issues i will help you i'll
help you i'll help you out bro go to go
to mode editor first
oh no no i got to get people in here so
i could see people oh okay okay okay
there's king there's king
nah
i was in the lobby no it was glitched
he was crazy the lobby was glitched
yeah
why everything in this game is good
dude wait till 2023 it'll be good then
at this time at this rate wait till
2025.
i mean 20-33
because it broke
okay so accept an invite
and then once you get in here go to
observer but king king's the only one
that's not going to be an observer
okay hold on let me get back into yours
i need to get some favor don't don't you
switch
yeah it's just switching me from one to
another it's not letting me switch to
observer jesus christ
oh no no i think i can join attitude
three four three
yeah joint game oh i can't join a game
look i see all the messages guys i you
know we'll play one more game after this
and we'll probably move on to something
else uh tyson bancho
299 and 20 43 halo will be a complete
game
yeah 20 33 yeah that's what that's what
three years all right everybody to
observer but me and king
they went we can't switch to observer
for something yeah there's something
there
yeah
he can't switch to a server he doesn't
let me i'm either cool
observers are off in the lobby options
yeah you have to go into the lobby
options
turn it on manually
all right so lobby options
observers yeah on okay now try there you
go
there you go
everyone to observe it
i'm still trying to get in
all right i got you man i'll send you
another invite
all right that's what they tell me and
people want to play it
three four three they're three four
three oh i don't know
yummy go to observer
um
you gotta hit the right bumper right
back that time
you got to move over press uh right
bumper that's what i'm doing but it's oh
wait there you go
all right i got it
did it work maybe we'll start i guess
we'll just do two two these are our two
all right all right okay so pick king
you get you get a pick
i get first pick yes you get first pick
and you know and this
by no means
you know
says who i like the most
he's gonna pick he's gonna pick whoever
he got killed by the most in the last
case
well i'm gonna tell you right now um
only a fool won't pick not jack so not
jack get over here
let's go
like ten more than that jack
jack listen i'm not
you know what you know what i ain't go
you know
i don't see madrid there either yes he's
not dead
so i i listen i i know what i'm doing
you know what hold up hold up hold up
hold up hold up
[ __ ] j come on over here to the winning
team if you can't get jordan you get
kobe bryant
i'll take that i'll take that i'm like a
young steph curry all right you you
picked next
all right i got next right hold on hold
on it's three to two right now
um definitely jeff leopard left uh
um yeah was the ability to get out of
there oh okay okay okay
all right
no no no no no hold up hold up hold up
that's not fair madrid wasn't there
that's not fair
no
that is not fair batman was not there
that man was not there
no no i gotta go [ __ ] i gotta go
[ __ ] madrid was not there
listen man
listen oh god
madrid i actually drove all right all
right all right fine fine you get madrid
come on over here phantom correct come
on over here fam all right
all right i got madrid i'm waiting for
madrid to come over
there you go
all right there we go all right so you
got um so you took that right all right
all right all right all right hey listen
life ain't fair sometimes you gotta get
over there
i personally feel like king messes
madrid to tell them yo leave dear to
addicts
all right all right all right now hold
up hold up hold up
[ __ ] j pick my pick that's how i'm
confident i'm letting someone else pick
my pick king
i'm sorry prince
sorry prince i'm sorry prince come on
over prince
prank
all right all right all right all right
all right hold on hold on hold on
hold
on hmm
see i i do got a lot of supremacy on it
live let's go
and i had 47 kills janine come over here
cheney let's go come over here cheney
hargicini let's go
dovah come on man come on home dave come
on home
rover rover send over over
dark defender get your ass up here we
got we got we got to watch
it
yeah
[Music]
[Music]
see these are all good dudes man
hmm
how about you pick two and i pick two
make it interesting no
no how about no
no i got got with him guys
you're on the eagles sir
dark defender come on home
i thought
let's go let's go post him
i'm not i'm gonna be last pick
we want players who said that who said
they gonna be last pick ain't no such
thing as last pick
that's mvp tangled come on come on
okay i don't want to hear that's the
reason why y'all lost death let's get it
all right
what are we playing
btb slayer
ptv slayer okay
what are we playing slaughterhouses
[Laughter]
so it'll be the next next we need one
more person
get one more person in
you got like the best people in this
layer wait it's in the middle we have
nine right on that extend you gotta use
the map you can choose the map this
you need one more person addict i think
we're good i think we're good the way it
is
uh no i think you need one more person
all right let me get one more person let
me get one first
all right then the master wanna come in
one two you're lucky i can't play the
sort of house record right now because i
would definitely king pick a number
between one and seven
we got some good perks over here between
between one and seven
yes god loves two
two okay look what you're coming in here
i had seven
uh
seven did we get lucid down here anybody
anybody got loose says
he said please
call the developer for bungie
we need lucid on this squad
guarantee the win
i hear that
i hit that guy
[Music]
i ain't got to worry about not jack
shooting me oh god we're good
that's why you're at the bottom of
exactly i don't care i i had a lot of
sense i was there and i was in the
background distracting you like
that that's right he was like kill i'm
always a team player i'm never jordan
all right there we go
did we get the extra person how's he
going
i have guys on dave he's gonna get in
here
that's right
he's not even in here yeah just switch
guys to the other team and then
come over here guys
yeah that'll work welcome to the cobra
car oh no we gotta get just for
switching over let's go guys this is
nice
but it's 19 people so it's just going to
be 10 you gotta tell like
king over here got like
all-star team real life
okay so listen listen listen listen
listen good money goes a long way god
bless you there you go
we're good huh all right
we don't talk out here all right so are
we good
you guys are down by one king yeah it's
fine you said we down by one player yeah
your team said it's fine your team said
it's fine remember
i i know they said this one you know
they're going to use it as an excuse
i don't think we're going to use it as
an excuse
[Music]
yep you know who just joined right
that guy's a pro
he's a certified killer he's a murderer
you know
legends has been taught about him all
right scuff control is on everybody
let's go
scriptures have been written
all right
i think everybody and everybody on
adam's team go to game chat
yeah we go to game chat
hello does this even work
i don't even think game chat works
there you go
all right
yeah quick get up out of here don't you
touch me
over [ __ ] on my hand
you coming up behind y'all
oh you get that
mind if i do oh commander rifle
probably flipped
yeah
because i'm in the backyard
with the the size clothes on
that's right he looked up to the 50s
he saw
you thought you had me but you didn't
you found out what i was getting
yeah that's why i dropped it
yeah
feeling free
oh broke your jaw punched you in your
face and knocked your teeth out oh my
god
you shot me in the back you acted like
you you beat me in fair combat
no
huh
if i put bullets upon you
where you at i ain't killed you it's a
close knife
it's only a close match
because we want it to be
oh wow
okay
all right guys spread them out
oh man
oh i'm dead
yeah no gunner
oh
that guy's trying it he's trying it
he's trying it
ah there's too many
[Laughter]
oh my god
it's called run down on them
we're too busy running down on you you
don't see us coming
my vehicle job spawn drop spawn flip
so i don't grab it
you know how to spawn flip right cause
we ran in your spawn and you had to run
the other way
let's go
what we're talking nonsense someone
oh it was like five of them over there
god bless
phantom
they're shooting over here from the from
the middle
relocate relocate
trying
who's my victim for this pistol work
i haven't put this [ __ ] working in a
minute
there's like five on me
yeah these teams are not balanced at all
man
you're gonna keep hearing five on your
paws that's how we do it there
it's
come this way from magento
come with me if you want to live
prince my dude i told you i wanted you i
want it
man the madrid dude is just hard to out
shoot seriously
what's going on
cash is good out here son
yo
[Music]
where they at i hit crickets
illusion illusion oh i just need to warm
up
you know
you got stretched
oh
oh somebody is killing somebody horrible
i hear bodies dropping
ground vehicle requisition oh ground
vehicle
let's go
[Music]
attic they're going to another lobby
help you
look at you
acting like you don't have
you guys you don't got like 18 right
i don't care about
those questions bro
[Music]
that's a whole new problem
like
you like
i love you baby come on man what's up
and he got that little halo around his
head
princess crazy as hell
come on seeing me six down he's bringing
brad's bringing breakfast everybody
spawn up man spawn up don't don't get
don't give them kills
spread them out spread them out
guys
give me more spread them out
don't give them kills man
i got killed
hey behind your behind
the lead is yours
all right guys just calm down man we got
this just calm down
just calm down get them kills man work
together get them you guys got this
pizza you guys
you guys can do this man just two more
just kill two more people one more get
one more person
all right guys we caught you outside
tell me he wouldn't be way extra if he
won that
oh no definitely would have attic i was
coming for your head trust me oh trust
me
pause pause
yeah i picked the right team you know
what it was man i believed in my people
all right so listen listen listen if you
pick the right team then run that back
running back i don't know i don't know
if i feel like i don't know if i feel
obligated to run anything back
i said run it back run it back
[Laughter]
wait guys
guys
let's make this interesting
let's make this interesting
next time let's make this interesting
again and the loser got to bend the knee
the next iop
wow why would i do that
oh now look at you you're being all
serious now
yo listen if y'all never played with me
now y'all know let's go
that's right
he said i heard baby old and i love him
i said don't let him rub baby all in his
nipples not me oh man him oh they're all
nanny pick it up let's go
for sure let's go let's go let's go
let's go yeah same thing different map
let's go different map let's go okay i'm
doing it calm down
you better put those all natty shirts on
then you don't need it
okay
but y'all
don't need it
okay
hey listen guys
remember what we said remember when they
went to the other lobby what we said we
were gonna let them win that don't let
them win oh oh okay
that's what we're doing
appreciate appreciate the concern you
know i appreciate it
i love i don't want nobody to press for
the weekend it's a nice weekend oh yeah
yo
huh
yeah and it's labor day weekend y'all
know barbecues outside last weekend
you're getting saucy you're about to go
to school next week
[Laughter]
i see my weapon
if there is one
hey jacob look out
what
[Laughter]
delicious
yeah
[Music]
stuff out of here
look at you acting like you you
you in a positive because you ran us off
of [ __ ] off the map when i grabbed you
[Laughter]
and not jack supposed to go
man
sorry buddy y'all still awesome that's
still going to be i don't care
they don't it don't matter
is this for the knee or not
let's go for the need let's take their
knees man y'all talking about oh now now
it's for the
[Laughter]
no you should have done that before you
can't see here and look at the look at
the the motion going on right now i'll
say yeah let's do it now why where was
this energy at the beginning of the game
exactly
quiet
god
look at that grenade
let's stack up on the right man let's
stack up on the right let's stop having
this
all right i'll take the assist
sorry
you thought i was there but i wasn't
there
can you dig it
he said i got king you got my bootstraps
boy
on top
yeah i've killed you like three times
this game it's definitely worth it i
didn't know i didn't see it cause i only
died once shut up lion
they're coming on the left left left
pull back but there's not enough of us
let them come up the hill
[Music]
just hold ground don't try to advance
hold ground
adam said don't fight him just take it
yo when we kill him just kill him in
bunches
that name sounds disgusting
over here over here on me
it's like flanking
oh my god you're trying to get me got
that
the
listen i got lotion on it's calamine
don't you talk about my stuff
oh no
oh you guys are getting jumped calamari
oh break his heart there you go break
his heart there you go
he thought he had a win
um
that's me sir
congratulations y'all getting
slaughtered
[Music]
everyone clamp up on the right man climb
up on the right
is that everybody
do something other than what you're
doing
oh
let's go we got this we got this
they said
snipers
they said interesting it's needed
help more ammo
hold your ground
guys 87-94 man you guys got this 88 to
94.
it's not over till it's over
push your wig back
one
two one
[Music]
oh
what we're going to do now we're going
to play uh four guys yeah let's play
something else now let's play something
else
you guys want to play
you guys want to play among us
thankful
yeah oh yeah
let's let's do four guys or something
because it's three o'clock my wife won't
punch my head off yeah we'll just play a
couple games of among us and call it a
day
yes sir i gotta head out all right man
[Music]
it's not snitching king nobody likes to
snitch
poco you gotta do poo poo let me come on
oh no no no actually my stop snitching
mug
is coming
pause
huh oh yeah yeah of course you know how
it goes and when i talk about the sony
topic yeah
all right the code the code is uh uuhf
uuhvfg that's the code
we're playing four guys right no we're
playing among us
among us
okay you're about to get deceded
i have no idea you know i just got
stupid stuff
ball guys
let me let me call my wife
[Music]
man this quick resume really slows down
your downloads man
i was at like 29 yeah hold on yeah yeah
i see
u-u-h-v-f-g
okay
what was that yeah what was the code
once again real quick
you might be able to just join the
invite i said yeah
yeah yeah i'm in
i'll play one of these
now for all for all reference i have not
played this in a long time
i don't think i've ever played this on
the xbox
yeah so and like it's about i only
played it
i'ma stay in the group
i don't know how you guys played um with
everybody talking but when we play it is
like whoever died yeah just can't talk
but how it is is you don't talk once you
uh once you die all right cool same
rules
oh i'm here
we do need one spot for king guys so i
had to kick someone if we get too many
people
i see my drip i see the drip
there's a gift for the cruise spartan
helmet oh i'm gonna redeem that
oh i got a lot of stuff oh italian
business
thread count
oh so we know
well change your clothes when you get in
here
because they're they're yeah hurry up
get in here it's it's it's filled up
fast no
my name is delta glance
you have to go back and change it go to
the main menu and change it
that's your id okay
their
little computer up there the laptop oh
laptop yeah
if you can send gallons
again i had to do some updates
and they don't have like all the roads
things no you can't do that
right there
yeah you have to go i i remember you had
to go to the main menu to change stuff
like that yeah yeah change your name
yeah i don't care about all that like
that man i'm not crazy like that god
bless i'll be me
you know me by the crown that's on my
head you hurt
yeah yeah for sure all right uh everyone
in here
uh
i'll put my coven mask on
that dude over there with the dress look
like he coughed
he called
he saw him he saw his dress move
we got see we didn't dress cool what
y'all doing that dude right there is
naked
are you guys ready
young man is buff naked out here nah
all right
change the color
bro
but nicky may be the one you know you
don't wanna out here talk about nine
inches stay from away from me get away
from me bro
this guy here
oh man nine inches just to kill him
oh man
remember if you die no more talking
don't talk hey don't talk unless you're
in the emergency thing
or and if you die you can't talk at all
yeah
oh we can't talk throughout the game
no if you die you die you have to take
your mind off because you can't give
away if you die yeah yeah yeah buddy
before you die
i don't know i don't know
i don't know
during the game
on the loading screen
you're not supposed to say stuff like
that
well we don't know if that's real yet if
you have to load
did that did that force you guys to an
emergency meeting
we'll just do we'll just load up another
one i don't know what happened there
okay
lead the game right all right
and that sucked too because i was i was
the killer
i'm sorry 343 developers too
oh my god
right right
the game i love halo
[Music]
i love the way it is
[Music]
they were very ambitious with the stuff
that they were doing where they were
yeah
they should have kept the multiplayer
like how to get halo 5 and then like
just content drops like that
look i'm coming i could crazy 343 all
day but at the same time
they're lower
they had a whole bunch of contractors
that left and remember they had a whole
support studio in russia and after the
war they had to split
so they lost how many people in that in
that studio in russia
but
for no reason all right i'm starting
is everyone in here
yeah it seems like but that's not
counting like halfway up to development
yeah we have 15 people we only have 11.
yeah but i mean do you really want to
sit around and wait for people
is that true that we're making a hero
shooter
i i can no i i don't comment on halo
rivers
okay
i'm innocent
i promise
uh
easy
pass i get killed
get in there
oh
they're fine did that do it
away from me i don't i don't like you oh
[ __ ] there's a party
[Music]
where was everybody there was a dead
body on the bottom left
innocent i saw the one in
you two are yeah each other that you
didn't do it hold on yes all right that
that kind of means
don't even try that no you know what
joey it's you it's you i don't know
i just kind of
like okay wait wait what was everybody
so joey's level 12 right and he said how
do you record the body acting like he
hasn't played this game
i was the boss no i wasn't quiet i
talked first that played this game
huh
i don't know yeah i was talking first i
said i found a body on the bottom left
but you ain't recording women hold on
you found the body yes right when i was
clicking why
hold up hold up
let me speak no no no no no i found the
body on the top
right uh top left corner i found and i
was uh uh lamparis i was with him
i found it
there was a body on the bottom left or
right when i went to click wide the
emergency meeting happened what i want
to know is how is [ __ ] j and lump
already voted we ain't even talk so i
kind of think that one of them is is it
man
i'm sure the imposter didn't like you
over here killing people obviously
you're going to want to bury me yeah i
mean
watch your previous stream man i don't
know
i feel i feel like jake and jay moving
real suspicious
with anybody
[ __ ] j is moving real
[Laughter]
dead people don't talk
okay i'm not voting but i think it's
[ __ ] just skips that's good
he wouldn't i would say he could have
killed me though if it would have been
we were both in there honestly i skipped
i was [ __ ]
you were convinced that it's me
i don't know man
i think it's joey
no no no i told you joey too though
my tasks
okay
that one
there it is
i'll make you think
come here chicka jay i'm not gonna call
you out yet but oh
chicka james
how's you following me
get on the mic get on the bike
okay
but what i will say jk and i think you
you would you would
you would say it too i could have killed
you multiple times man hold up and there
was a dude dead in an electrical that
you know for a fact i didn't commit
that's all i want to say i didn't see
nobody
i actually didn't do it
wasn't electrical that was good
it was me and jerry i just came from no
i would don't know but i just came from
admin doing my task
and then i was going to lecture to do my
next one and then there was a guy in the
corner i'm like ah [ __ ] but the bad part
is i was the first to come in that kind
of looks like i did it
so
he was talking on party chat right when
he was running out and then i ran in and
reported
all right so okay so let's let's recap
let's recap
no no no
i'm gonna accept it it looks bad when i
went in because when i went in i saw the
body i'm like ah [ __ ]
how did you afford it
because the other guy reported first at
me but he was saying it too so he
probably just didn't know
so so are we saying hold up hold up hold
up who's the two people hold up hold up
hold up let's clear let's clear the air
let's clear the air guys let's click i
could have killed adding a long time ago
because i was doing a test he was next
to me we were both by ourselves i could
have killed him or attic or emperor one
of those two i could have killed both of
y'all you know man i'm very offended
that you confused me with someone else
i'm kind of thinking you might get
out of there then i found the body all
right so so i feel like
i feel like we shouldn't i'm struggling
through this reaction that's what i'm
doing i'm struggling i'm brilliant i
feel like y'all should know that it's
not me who's not talking by the way
uh
and he was innocent oh [ __ ]
language all right
i still think it might be choice i'm not
going to move i forget joey i only got i
only got one task left i only got one
guys
so i'm trying to go to my past and i
don't trust y'all
[Music]
so okay hear me out guys
hold up
hold it was me hear me out
not jack
was on me like white on yes
it's like he was waiting for the
opportunity to make me dead
no i'm done my test how's this hanging
hold on hold on
i think
that's just my opinion okay i reported
the last body okay so you act like
self-report is it a thing
no no no no no that's not fair because
i was spotting you somebody has to
report it that happened to me
okay who's talking i was spotting you
i'll spot someone else
um
i don't think we got enough info here
all we got is adam
let's go back let's go back i don't
think we have enough here i'm just
telling you just so you guys know
i wasn't feeling the way not jack was
following me that's all i know
hmm who's that
yeah he's not speaking or she
that's why he's like the one who's not
voting
oh man they voted
oh you guys voted not jack
again i'm gonna clarify i got one task
left
after that i'm staying in the middle i
can't get to my channel y'all creeping
where is it all right i'm creeping
i'm trippin
hold on man i don't know about these
lives find me
i know they're looking looking suspect
over here my jacket is here too
and blind spot me get away from me
oh why is it taking so long to know
you see that somebody sabotages the so
you think it's me
kind of unsatisfied
i was in the dining room the whole
cafeteria
[Music]
i knew it
it was yellow yellow i saw him he i saw
him on the cameras he killed that man
get yellow up out of here
joey crack you are out
we caught you red-handed not jack was
there you know come to think of it maybe
maybe i should have let not jack talk
first to see if he was the the the
offender as well
because people believe you no one is
that
joey with the knife
in the cafeteria that's who it was
no no no no no no that's not true
explain to yourself down in the
cafeteria somebody
where did the body appear no no we saw
it on cameras
just get yellow up out of there we don't
even like the color yellow anyway like
why are we letting him stay around like
just get him up out of here
it's over yellow
now red vote yellow
come on red there you go not blue vote
yellow let's go live spicy vote yellow
yellow yellow
yellow not there my dog
it's joey
it's joey
who voted him
bye bye yellow
um
hey
all right guys we looking for we looking
for another murderer
they're not on the cameras
it's red i think it's red
shout out to uh k johnson with the five
iron lords uh podcast membership so
appreciate it
i think it's red
yeah we're not letting
blue get to me
blue's coming for me
oh blue being real suspect
i don't know man it's blue or red
i think it's red because he keeps trying
to separate one of us
see if he cuts chases after me
yep he got him you got him we good good
i told you man red was acting real
suspect real suspect all right blue
i know you don't know me
style red murder attic
yo let's see if he does this guys is he
going to be able to convince a random
dude that it was red
i don't think they have much guys
use the chat
hey chad help me out
come on chat you know we can hear you
through the like after
it's red for sure blue oh
it's red it's red blue don't vote for
the chief let's go
bro okay so
first of all yeah you got it let me get
let me get my point out i knew it was
joey because at this start he said how
do you report a body and he's been
playing this game before and you're like
oh because i had kids
i knew
[Music]
[Music]
yeah we're gonna play we're gonna play
like two more games than we're gonna
call today
you gotta roll through without me
brother
all right um i have one more person to
take my spot
the going to punch me in the nose
i'm only going to play one or two more
games and then i'm oh
the game is over
yeah yeah because i oh he's saying y'all
a new one
oh
let me uninstall this halo
but i'm mine the wrong one on this one
yeah
just join this innocence right my bad
join the other one
yeah yo nine nine inches is dead with me
i'm like come on man
hey kid you saw it right yo yo yo i had
to say paul i was i was walking out
[Music]
i i
from the graveyard
yo we gotta set up some tournaments with
some street fighter and some stuff so i
can get some real trash talking all
right this is the last game we're doing
this is gonna be interesting i put our
vision of [ __ ]
they could they have to be real close to
us to kill us
and there's three imposters
last game man three imposters
but they have to be really close to us
to kill us
so you can kill from far away i didn't
know how that worked
all right cool
oh why is it already dark what's going
on
wait hold on hold on what's going on
oh no i did that all right you get
killed from afar
i don't trust joey at all
all right come on man
look at me i'm innocent
yeah okay
how do you report the bodies
i can't see nobody man why is it
starting off like this is scary
it's scary lights is off
the lights are all um
all right guys it was great hanging out
with you uh this was just fun we're
gonna do a whole lot more of these
things
you know trying to do them during the
week we got some more stuff coming
all right
thanks guys i had so much fun
appreciate you guys oh
like i don't know
person you killed that
hands down now i want to say you think
that because i look ugly like that like
scream you're prejudiced you think i'm a
killer
i'm just saying it
it's not getting ready it's like people
don't mind stereotyping
i am
[Music]
you can't fix the lights i made it that
on purpose
[Applause]
all right i'm going to navigation
where am i shooting
why is this dude still in the game
anyway he's not on our party right who's
not in nobody's right
oh god
so just to clarify chat
i'm not gonna say who's the killer uh
because i feel like some of these people
are watching but he he caught me good
and clean
just let me all know i didn't want to
walk past it and not report it
where was it at because i just got off
of the camera it was like a little bit
ago so i was in the reactor
i was on the camera how do i tell where
i was on the right side i was on the
right side of the back i was on the left
side far away
i was on that bench i don't need you
joey but
i was on the right side y'all
i'm just letting you know sir
i think it might be uh
look kick me out go ahead
let's see how you guys look
make a thumbnail i don't know that's
pretty probably not safe
to be safe
and suspect like right now
i mean
where were you at bro
you ain't got a mic you can't get on
mike i think oh you got it hey
you leave here where were you at
i was an admin trying to swap credit
card
actually biannually a little bit uh
you're a little bit talkative so um
i voted for you
i'm pretty sure there's three kills um
where's the
i can't remember though okay
oh i don't know how to play this one
uh
don't do it
oh i did it again
i got it
ghosts do your tasks they can win if
they don't kill everybody and you
freaking do your tasks
both for them
by the way
yeah it i'm gonna keep the stream open
for a couple more minutes but i'm
leaving the party
have fun with you guys
youtube
all right so that's pretty much the
stream guys you know uh we
we we've been talking about a lot about
how to give back to the to the community
uh you know we do got a long way to go i
feel like we can do more with the
community
um
the biggest thing is just finding enough
time for all of us to do it but i think
we're officially gotten to the point
where we're willing to break that
uh
what i'll probably do
in order for a community stream is put
some kind of goal together like
depending on memberships and patreons
and maybe put some artwork on the
podcast for it
uh you know and we
generally get that every time so i don't
think that's going to be a big issue but
you know i appreciate everyone for
coming through and until next week next
sunday
at 1 p.m let me see if uh if we have a
guest for next sunday
what's today's the the fourth that means
it'll be the 11th
september the 11th oh okay so i know
who's coming on next week but i
appreciate we got a uh
k johnson with the member chat been a
member for eight months told y'all it
was joey with the screen mask yeah uh
one of them got me up out of that i
can't remember which one man but one of
them got me up out of there pretty sure
ever coming through it's like i said
we're gonna do more of this we're going
to play a lot more with the community
because i enjoyed it and we're going to
you know probably i know you guys want
our takes on like marvel stuff movie
stuff i'll probably put that in there i
want to put like monthly goals and if we
hit those goals that month what we'll do
is we'll do more stuff like this
because you know what the problem is we
all of us individually are just
extremely busy and it's hard
to get everyone together but i think you
know we do certain things because we are
planning on going like
plan on going to gamescom next year
hopefully we're planning on going maybe
the tokyo games we're planning on going
to more stuff so i do think you know i
can incentivize like look we have these
goals if we meet these goals to put
money into into the into the iron bank
to help go to these trips we do more
stuff and i think i can i can i can
easily sell that a lot easier uh but i
appreciate it for coming through it's
like i said you guys did fantastic last
month we had
crazy support from you guys from
watching to super chats to liking the
podcast we had a couple podcasts last
multiple over a thousand likes i don't
know if you guys realize how hard it is
to get over a thousand likes and i
appreciate all of you guys from doing it
like i said we will be doing more stuff
i i think i got a
good incorporate that you know members
chat thing where you know you can talk
to uh you can ask us questions during
these streams i think instead of doing
at the beginning i might do it through
the whole show like after we play one
game might play a game for an hour might
play like two and a half maybe three
hours and all and then after ever again
we'll answer a couple questions with the
people that from the realm that's coming
in the chat but i appreciate ever coming
through and until next time we will see
you next week we're out of here peace